eux qui vont réagir sur le casting de
d'ébrité alors on a des noms donc
candice pascal alexandra rosenfeld
jean marc généreux et des anneaux gaba
gérard vivès et à notre ami julien
lepers autant dire que le casting boost
bien vous attendiez acquis audio
d'animateurs qui était déjà calamiteux
dans vos colis de drogue cfoot sa
mauvaise dégager quelque chose d'un
fiasco
rien n'est facile la peau un vieux
concept et un casting mais c'est même
plus de la seconde zone là c'est de la
balle jaune à l'horaire série alexandre
à kamel sympathie alors je vous pose une
question après les autres et son jeu
conditionnelle à la belle vous créez une
émission oui vous prenez ces gens là bas
vous avez vu que j'ai pris alors non
sans déconner le casting dites moi
vraiment ce que vous en pensez mais je
vous préviens je veux quelqu'un
d'honnête honnête on est sur la queue de
leur mort honnêtement il est
catastrophique et revêtements ce qui est
triste c'est que côté sont revenus à tf1
il est vraiment premier à la chaîne ctv
qui produit qu'ils allaient avoir du
thierry lhermitte et quelques surprises
souvenez-vous même marginale de match et
on à l'époque quelques vrais noms
qu'elle et revenir avec des artistes et
ça serait intéressant mais comme
toujours il ya ce qu'on veut qu'elle a
failli à ce qu'on a assez comme elle en
a regardé tous vues ne pas se retrouver
avec un instant un petit peu le
sentiment de s'être fait un peu berner
parce que c'est parce qu'on leur a vendu
son faire fumer après voyons là je
reconnais que c'est une cata ils sont
faits en fumée mais jean michel adam de
toute façon c'était l'émission titre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'émission qui l'a elle date de quand 10
ans 15 ans 13 ans y avait une édition
elle est pas marché c'est un tout un
plat pour qu'elles reviennent vides
revient c'est quoi l'histoire l'a le
plus fort ses ballades alice moura
beaulac une édition c'est tout je vais
arrêter
oui pour moi c'est la salle de danse
avec les stars en fait on recycle les
gens ont désormais avec les stars et on
va aller voir mon ce programme la seule
chose bien dans ce programme
c'est que l'argent n'est pas pour leur
pomme c'est pour y associer ils envoient
de l'argent quand même gérant des royals
au pays des minimoys est le même que
parfois ils n'ont pas de sens on leur en
donne une dix minutes après l'abeille et
comme là mais c'est normal ils sont
payés d'abord dit des bêtises je suis je
vous aime énormément vous dites une
énorme bêtise vous expliquer le concept
de je suis une célébrité je vous
expliquais concept de danse avec les
stars danser les stars vous venez vous
dansez vous prenez un cachet chaque
semaine si vous restez je suis une
célébrité me prenais à cacher pour aller
dans l'émission et après vous avez des
épreuves voilà et bien entendu ces
épreuves ils vont pas donner l'argent
aux célébrités ils vont donner forcément
à des associations
c'est pas comme dans danse avec les
stars il n'y a pas d'épreuve dans danse
avec les stars c'est à dire qu'il ya
deux étapes
donc ils font des épreuves par exemple
est pas énorme et des cafards sur la
tête et ils disent voilà si vous restez
d'une demi-heure était qu'à partir des
saf et 5000 euros pour l'association
mais sait il se regarde filoniens c'est
bien que ce soit pour neda social un
énorme scandale
prenez des cafards sur la gueule prenez
5000 bull étonnant refusé deux dans le
casting c'est qu'ils ont refusé déjà
refusé l'ordre et l'euro et baptiste
giabiconi
mais c'est bien ce qu'ils avaient la
whey alors attendez quand et alors alex
goude voulait le faire et c'est le fait
bureau si luis fernandez mais finalement
leurs emplois du temps
n'empêche de le faire en revanche j'ai
appelé jean thomas qui effectivement a
été contacté mais qui du coup a refusé
de le faire
kevin et elle me signale nous avons re
signer mon cher bernard une nouvelle
saison de snap que je tourne super
février et cyril je vous dire vrai c'est
vrai que je suis là lepers apparemment
on va le faire
il paraît alors je vous le dis j'ai une
petite info paraît-il que pour la saison
en tout cas quand on est un gros nous ce
serait à peu près cent cinquante mille
euros 1 bon quand on dernière info le
petit benoît dubois
ah oui on va contacter lui en revanche
la production plusieurs faut rien faire
et je crois que c'est pour une question
d'image peut-être qu'il a une mauvaise
image mais pour l'instant ils le
refusent non mais vous il est très sympa
mais justement niveau image moi je
trouve que tf1 ait beaucoup de
programmes ceux de l'époque les
programmes de arturo par exemple danse
avec les stars il ya toujours on
retrouve toujours les mêmes visages
donc en fait ils recyclent il passe de
chez arthur à danse avec les stars la
main sur tara mais c'est normal aux
images c'est dur de trouver des
célébrités qu'ils peuvent faire et qui
n'ont rien à [ __ ] des gens sur ces 8
c'est pareil on ne recycle aussi nyala
qui ont des prime qui sont tournés vers
m et c'est très bien payé des frais oui
c'est l'économie aussi et c'est l'école
la raison non c'est la région la semaine
dernière on avait en prime de ouf avec
benjamin castaldi kelly vdev ni
franchement moi je tue le producteur de
cette émission ils ont été très fiers